intelligence is rate of learning so if I
showed you all a red card and then I
slapped you you'd be like whoa and I
don't say anything and then I show you a
red card and then I slapped you be like
whoa and then I showed you a red card
and then you duck same condition new
Behavior if I show you that and it takes
some person 10 times for them to duck
and one person the second time they duck
the second time person is smarter
they're more intelligent than the 10
time person a lot of you here think
you're really smart but you go back home
to the same condition and you do the
exact same thing so how smart are You by
defining it that way it actually makes
intelligence under our control but if
you leave here and your behavior doesn't
change in the same conditions it means
you learned nothing